hi everyone today you're watching man
carrying the legacy of the motion
picture industry Cinema is dying Cinema
isn't Marvel I think I have this mixed
up if you're anything like me then
you've been noticing some crazy hot
takes lately thanks to Our Endless hot
take Factory called YouTube we sure love
talking about how bad TV is now and if
I've learned anything from these videos
it's that Marvel has killed Cinema or uh
more specifically franchise film making
has taken over the multiplex which is
true the traditional story for the past
decade or so has been movies are getting
bigger more expensive and studios are
reli in on the success of a few tent
pole films to keep them afloat and
because of this real art real film
making has been on the small screen the
small screen TV this has held true for
the past uh 15 20 years uh I mean for a
while we've been in the Golden Age of TV
but what do video posits is not
[Music]
anymore this video was sponsored by
Babel you know back in the day Nadia and
I used to know a lot of Spanish Nadia a
lot more than I did we took a lot of
classes in college where we met where we
spoke a lot of Spanish we've gotten
pretty bad at it which is why I'm very
happy to be sponsoring Babel fall is the
season of learning as they say why not
learn a new language Babel is one of the
top language learning apps in the world
lessons prepare you to have practical
conversations about travel business and
more Babel Has quite a few options of
subscriptions to choose from including a
lifetime subscription oh hell yeah I got
all those right one of my biggest goals
in life is to be able to read one of my
favorite books 100 Years of Solitude in
its original language I've just been
using phrases now Rand ly throughout the
day that I don't need to don't ask Doo
you know I know where the bathroom is I
live here I'm going to be a Spanish
speaking guy you have the option to
choose if you're more of a private
learner or if you're more of a vocal
learner get 60% off on your subscription
during their Black Friday sale Babble
offers a 20-day moneyback
guaranteed thank you to Babel for
sponsoring the video and remember to get
60% off on your subscription during
their Black Friday sale click on the
link in the description onto the video
it to talk about the TV landscape let's
begin with Disney specifically Marvel in
a recent variety piece Tatiana seagull
writes about the behind the scenes
problems at Marvel I just really love
that illustration of the guys just like
climbing up and then crashing down props
to whoever did that it's fine seagull
reports that Marvel has largely
succeeded due to the Steady Hand of
Kevin figy who and I didn't know this
just does everything not literally
everything but he has his personal
creative hands in everything at Marvel
from writing to C to editing in this way
he's like an old school Hollywood Mogul
probably makes sense when you're putting
out uh three huge movies a year but it
becomes a problem when your parent
company Disney decides hey it's co right
now okay they didn't decide that part
but as a consequence of Co they decided
hey we need numbers to do good and you
know what makes numbers do good
historically is Marvel seagull writes
the source of Marvel's current troubles
can be traced back to 2020 that's when
the co pandemic ushered in a mandate to
help boost Disney's stock price with an
endless torrent of interconnected Marvel
content for the studios fledgling
streaming platform Disney plus oh Disney
plus you were meant to be the chosen one
I remember when people were talking
about Disney plus like um it was going
to be the new Netflix like it was going
to overthrow
Netflix that was funny and they
encouraged people to sign up because
they were like hey we have exclusive MCU
TV shows that you have to watch like
Falcon show what is that Falcon in the
Winter Soldier show you have to stop
calling them terrorists and W division
in the following years since this
mandate the results have been mixed to
say the least Marvel was bleeding money
with a single episode of a single
episode of She-Hulk costing some $25
million dwarfing the budget of a final
season episode of HBO's Game of Thrones
that sounds like a fine financial
decision if you ask me but Iger publicly
acknowledging the downside of a Marvel
TV glut that diluted focus and attention
hey guys remember how I told you to make
a million shows well um I guess that was
a bad idea in a lot of ways Marvel's TV
production has been a case study and
what has become royally Fed Up in TV in
a way they are a product of the problems
they caused I mean skyrocketing budget
slow production confused writing TV used
to be um what did TV used to be what's
the word I'm looking for oh inexpensive
I mean it used to be simple I mean TV
used to be cheap TV I don't know if you
guys remember but TV used to look like
garbage and it used to be be bad and we
were just okay with that not a lot of
room for artistic expression in a lot of
ways the shows were basically there to
keep you watching ads I'm not saying
it's a good thing I'm just saying that's
how it used to be it's kind of funny
that CEOs like David zaslov want more of
that type of content now because it's it
is cheap and Michael shellman's New
Yorker piece which I legally read he
writes about Peter bis's new book
chronicling the rise and fall of
prestige TV comparing that era of of You
Know The Sopranos and madmen and
breaking B to the era of new Hollywood
in the late' 60s '70s at its most
ambitious the new Hollywood movement was
a movement intended to cut film free of
its evil twin Commerce enabling it to
fly high through the thin in air of art
so just like Easy Rider and mash were
flukes that happened to succeed in a
failing desperate system that was
clawing away from like big Studio
Productions Orange is the New Black and
Deadwood and house of cards were allowed
to flourish in an ecosystem that usually
stifles creativity tech companies were
taking over and now instead of money
being the prize the prize was legitimacy
and What Makes You legitimate in the
eyes of Hollywood winning golden naked
statues Showman's piece thoroughly
Chronicles the shifting landscape and
entertainment I suggest you read it
where do we from here the interesting
thing about tech companies they love
debt and they love spending money they
don't have which is the definition of
debt I think sooner or later the
streaming prices would go up and the ads
would proliferate everyone knew this
would happen you know how Netflix raised
their prices limited password sharing
and created an ad tier then like right
after uh every other service did the
same thing except Apple which is still
in the prestige era I think they do have
the morning show though Netflix had one
bad quarter and suddenly this entire
industry built on debt and empty
promises established
by taking risks and asking questions
later had to answer to their
shareholders and now they're like I need
my mommy I'm so scared of losing money
why did I put that in the script I need
you know it's the story of uber and
Airbnb after destroying the competition
with unsustainable prices they now
dominate providing largely the same
Services as before except worse more
expensive and with no protections for
their workers part of the big push to
streaming I think was that Studios
didn't have to pay you know the same
types of royalties to actors and writers
and everyone who worked on the streaming
shows the tech sort of allows them to
cut Corners around Union protections now
these Hollywood Studios having been LED
astray by the golden Promises of
streaming and after throwing their
entire business model into streaming
have discovered that hey um we're losing
money this isn't profitable and not only
is it not profitable it's providing a
arguably worse product I mean sure for a
while there they were taking risks on
exciting shows and movies uh and they
still will probably for a while but I
really think that era is coming to a
close at least starting to come to a
close shows like flea bag and I will
destroy you you know more like Indie
focused TV shows we'll get less and less
of a chance to see the light of day get
ready for Endless stranger things
spin-offs prepare yourself for Love is
Blind season 28 and even worse for the
poor Studios is that the writers and act
and craft people who work on these
streaming shows they actually want to
get paid what that's shouldn't be
allowed so this all culminated uh of
course in the SAG aftera and the riter
guild strikes that have just ended
leaving us in a new strange era of TV
and movies and the attitudes of studios
and streamers were will probably be like
really cautious unbearably cautious now
prices are going to go up and reliable
bankable content will be the norm
Ironically in all of this the most
reliable content on streaming services
is like syndicated Network TV from like
20 years ago recently the show Suits has
been like a phenomenon on streaming uh
you know it was just like standard
boring show Megan marle was in it but
they put it on Netflix and then all of a
sudden it's like the the biggest show in
the world of course the people who made
aren't going to seem like any money from
that that's like the show my dad would
watch while folding laundry you know
that's the type of old show that seems
so simple that I don't think like
streaming services know how to make
anymore what they do know how to make is
like $25 million episodes of a five
episode season that won't get a second
season for 3 years and they're wondering
why they're losing money I don't know
it' probably be funny uh if it all goes
back to the way it once was post network
streaming world could turn out to look
very much like the pre- streaming
broadcast World bisin concludes instead
of the big four networks we might see
big five streamers Marvel used to have
sustainable low stakes TV shows and I
imagine they will return to that model
soon shman writes the industry's default
setting is for crap occasionally the
incentives change just enough to allow a
Cascade of innovation but those
incentives inevitably shift back to the
norm it's almost like art in a
commoditized world is constantly
fighting a losing battle but what does
any of this matter to me it doesn't cuz
I watch YouTube where art is always the
priority thank you for
watching hey guys I don't usually do
these types of videos very often usually
I just uh passive aggressively express
myself in skits but I just wanted to say
a little more about this subject than
usual I just want to say thank you to my
patreons if you like this kind of stuff
please consider supporting me on patreon
uh these are my patrons right here
anyways thank you for watching it means
a lot thank you to my patrons thanks
everyone and thanks Babel for sponsoring
this video all right bye everyone